Mary and Megan have been feeling the
heat a lot these days and now we've
learned where they chose to escape for
the Thanksgiving holiday the Sussex clan
including nearly seven month old baby
our chief kept their visit under wraps
by staying in a secret location here in
the states they flew in to spend a quiet
holiday with Megan's mom Toria and could
even be staying through Christmas
I hear from quite reliable sources that
they may be using this trip as an
opportunity to look at some houses
they're still very much a feeling that
they're going to have a second home in
the States during this day maybe Megan
will swing by New York to see her good
friend designer Misha nunu the first
designer that I thought of immediately
was a really good friend of mine Misha
nunu only et got the invite to visit
Misha at her Manhattan pop-up store
where you can buy her famous husband
shirt than Megan wore on her first
official outing with Harry it was you
know obviously very exciting and she
looked so beautiful Megan and Misha
created a special edition of the shirts
for the charity smart works and of
course it's sold out so were you in the
Duchess's Essex working alongside each
other the Duchess asked me to create the
shot we had a couple of conversations
about what it should look like what she
was thinking and then she let me take it
to that do you call her the Duchess is
that six to her very I'm afraid I
wouldn't talk about any personal nature
the relationship
well when you're friends with royalty it
seems you're not allowed to talk about
it but I have to say I was thrilled when
me she suggested I try on the $185
shirts get a slip into my husband shirts
all right wait for the transformation
you'll be an me she showed me just how
to get a little bit of that Markel
sparkle when you're wearing a more
casual trouser like you are you can do a
little Demi tuck in the front
Demi tech you can also wear with one cup
like so or you can wear it with two
cuffs you're going out to cocktails or
going on date night well you can then go
like that and you can tell Lily
believe it
[Music]